Salut ! Aujourd'hui c'est le jour du Vlog, mais je ne vous emmène pas dehors, je vous emmène dedans.
Et plus précisément dans mes abonnements de YouTube.
Il y a 4 mois maintenant, c'était le 17 mars dernier, je vous faisais découvrir les 5 chaines qui me faisaient vraiment triper.
Je les suis toujours, elles me plaisent toujours autant et aujourd'hui je vous en fait découvrir des nouvelles que j'aime particulièrement.
Une nouvelle chaine que j'aime bien, qui commence à se mettre en place, c'est la chaine du Mnémonaute,
c'est David qui fait ça.
Comme son nom l'indique, c'est une chaine dédiée à la mémoire, il n'a pas forcément les mêmes angles d'attaque que moi, ou les mêmes présentations.
C'est vraiment 100% sur la mémoire, avec des applications très concrètes. Il a lancé la chaine il y a 3 mois et a 146 abonnés pour le moment,
mais tout ceux et celles qui s'intéressent à la mémoire, vous allez y trouver des trucs.
Une chaine qui me plait beaucoup c'est la chaine d'une pote Marine Baousson. Vous l'avez vu dans une de mes premières vidéos, au tout début de l'année.
En ce moment elle est au festival d'Avignon et à chaque fois qu'elle y est, elle fait des épisodes là-bas sur place pour pac à l'eau.
C'est toujours très drôle, c'est bien écrit, c'est bien filmé, c'est bien tourné. Aujourd'hui je me suis aperçu qu'elle n'avait que 600 abonnés
alors qu'elle est sur YouTube depuis tellement longtemps, et elle fait des trucs vraiment cools, vous pouvez regarder les anciennes vidéos qu'elle faisait pour pac à l'eau
qui sont très écrits et cette année c'est un petit peu différent puisqu'elle vlog son Avignon mais ça reste très drôle.
Et en plus dans les vidéos on voit pleins d'humoristes qu'on aime bien donc ça c'est cool.
Un de mes chaines préférées c'est la chaine de Chris, de Poisson Fécond. Son idée c'est de faire des vidéos qui sont plutôt instructives mais j'aime bien le traitement
j'aime bien la manière de s'exprimer, qui est plutôt calme d'ailleurs.
Le travail de recherche est cool, c'est bien écrit, encore une fois c'est bien tourné, c'est bien monté, et j'aime bien les chaines qui développe un univers complet.
Comme on peut le constater, il n'a pas vraiment besoin que je parle de lui, pour être bien dans le YouTube game, puisqu'il a plus d'un million d'abonnés.
Mais comme je vous parle des chaines que je kiffe, je n'ai pas pris comme restriction le nombre d'abonnés.
Il y a une chaine qui est assez ressente aussi, c'est celle de Lex Tutor. Enfin quand je dis assez ressente, elle est plus vieille que le Mental Vlog.
Je crois qu'il a eu un petit coup de pouce de la chaine e-penser, c'est comme ça que je l'avais découvert.
C'est un avocat en fait qui fait une chaine, il a plusieurs série mais celle que je préféré c'est celle qui s'appelle CGT.
En tant qu'avocat, il va traiter un sujet, qui pourrait être un sujet légal.
Comme cette vidéo: "Tuer un zombie est-il un meurtre ?"
Ca était ma bonne découverte de cette année sur YouTube, parce que je n'avais jamais vu de chaine qui parlait de lois et en mélangeant ça avec l'humour.
Et avec un contenu aussi intéressant.
Et pour terminer, la chaine d'un autre pote, qui s'appelle Max Bird.
C'est un pote qui est sur scène à la base, et le but de sa chaine c'est de détruire les idées reçues.
Et c'est très drôle. C'est bien fait, c'est intelligeant, et c'est très drôle.
Ca faisait un moment qu'il était dans ma liste des chaines dont je voulais vous parler quand j'allais faire cette vidéo,
sauf que entre le moment où j'ai décidé d'écrire cette vidéo où il avait 4 000 et le moment où je l'a fait, il a 129 000 abonnés.
Donc il a prit 125 000 abonnés en moins d'une semaine.
Pour deux raisons:
La première c'est parce que Doc Seven lui a fait une mise en avant sur sa chaine. L'excellente chaine de Doc Seven que je vous recommande, soit dit en passant.
Et la deuxième raison, c'est parce que sa chaine est vraiment qualitative. Je crois que c'est une des plus grosses entrées dans le YouTube game, j'ai lu ça dans un article.
Et donc allez voir la chaine de Max.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu. Si vous avez d'autres chaines que vous kiffez vraiment, pas de l'auto promo, je parle des chaines que vous aimez
vraiment, que vous voulez faire découvrir à la Team Mentalo, n'hésitez à le mettre dans les commentaires.
Quant à moi, je mettrai les cinq chaines dont je vous ais parlé dans le descriptif.
Personnellement, ça m'a fait plaisir de vous faire un vlog un peu différent. C'est pas vraiment un vlog, puisque je vous emmène dans mon ordinateur,
mais je trouvait que ça changeait un peu le rythme. Si jamais ça vous a plu, faites le moi savoir en laissant un magnifique et vloguant...
POUCE EN L'AIR !
Allez je vous tease un petit peu sur cette semaine...
Demain je mentalise un mec qui s'appelle Victor Barange.
Mercredi, parce que vous me l'avez demandé, je vous donne des astuces pour se faire augmenter ou pour négocier.
Je vais voir quel angle je vais prendre, je suis en train de l'écrire.
Et jeudi je fais la FAQ pour fêter les 30 000 abonnés.
Si vous avez une question, n'hésitez pas à me la poser sur Twitter en mettant le #mentalisme30000.
Le mentalisme du futur !
Vous êtes nombreux à m'avoir demandé pourquoi on faisait la FAQ sur Twitter,
je vais vous le dire, c'est pour deux raisons:
La première c'est parce qu'à chaque fois que je fais quelque chose avec vous, j'essaie de changer de réseau social, pour pénaliser personne.
Donc une fois c'est Fabebook, Instagram, un coup c'est Snap, un coup c'est Twitter...
Et la deuxième raison, c'est que vous n'êtes peut-être pas sans savoir, que depuis début juillet je n'ai plus Internet.
J'ai changé d'opérateur, pour prendre la fibre de chez Free, et ça ne fonctionne toujours pas, je crois qu'il m'ont complètement oublié,
malgré mes relances et mes appels...
D'ailleurs si jamais il y a un ou une d'entre vous qui travaille chez Free et qui peut m'aider à faire accélérer ça, parce que c'est pas possible en fait,
je suis en train de tout télécharger en 4G, etc.
Ce qui m'amène à pourquoi je n'ai pas fait de FAQ Snapchat par exemple, c'est parce que j'ai trop peur que ça rame trop, et que je rate vos snaps...
Bref ! Si vous travaillez chez Free, contactez moi, ça me ferait grand plaisir, qu'on puisse résoudre ça. Parce que quand tu mets une vidéo
par jour, t'as envie de te jeter par la fenêtre...
Mais comme c'est au rez-de-chaussée ça ne sert à rien...
Si vous avez une question relative à mes vidéos en général ou à YouTube, vous mettez la question sur Twitter avec le hashtag.
Passez une excellente semaine. N'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de partir.
Et rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !